welcome calculator fanciers today we
have an unusual calculator to unbox my
name is matt parker and here on
numberphile i will be looking at this
casio which is a well-known calculated
brand i'm going to make other things but
i very much suspect this is not going to
be an electronic keyboard in here is
some kind of calculator although not in
the normal aspect ratio very interesting
and there's there's scant details on the
outs i mean look at this this side's
blank that side's blank i mean that's an
entire what's that like a third of all
the faces on this box are blank the only
real information here is that it's a
one-to-one scale which means that
whatever's in there is an exact
one-to-one scale to what it is in
reality that's quite in fact most
physical objects tend to be a one-to-one
scale but anyway so we'll pop this open
we'll get our scalpel here and again
we're going to very carefully use the
scalpel to just flick open the top there
right and if we open it up we can see
here we go it's a casio
data bank watch oh yes you can see
that they have covered it with a kind of
hood and it's sufficiently transparent
so you can start to get excited about
what's in there it's a little bit of a
tease but the main reason they do that
is so you can have a grand unveiling so
you can hold this and you can lift it
off sit and then
there you are look
no better way to open a calculator than
that and you have a display stand so
when you bring it home after a hard day
of calculating on the go you can put it
back on the display stand it's got a
special handle there for picking up the
display stand should you not want to
risk getting fingerprints on the rest of
it and there is a little spot here for
the instruction manual look at that just
crammed in there they have shoved the
manual in there
which if we fold it out so we get a
variety of shapes should you be
uncertain as to what
those shapes would be for californian
usa only so if you try and use this
outside california they cannot guarantee
it will give you mathematically accurate
uh answers that's very good what else is
going to leap out okay the rest of this
is just standard instruction booklet
although in a slightly different ratio
this is the wide screen version of the
instruction booklet which is great so
let's have a look at the calculator
itself take it off the stand uh this is
here this this is for adjusting uh where
this is it can be there or there or
anywhere in between it's quite nice it's
a continuous thing there's a uncountably
infinite number of places you could put
that it's quite nice uh and then there
is there is a very finite set number of
places you can lock this into position
so i i feel like
i mean the main feature of this is the
fact that you can attach it to your
wrist you can you can strap it on and
that is very important very few
calculators can do that in fact i've got
another for comparison casio calculator
here and if you try and balance that on
your it's incredibly difficult to do
calculations on your wrist and should
you be you know holding a drink or
something and you haven't got the use of
this hand and you need to do a
wrist-based calculation this is a
terrible idea whereas this is going to
go on quite quite snugly and firmly and
you just slide
that through there here we go you adjust
it to the you round the diameter well
you i guess you use using the
circumference of your wrist to the
nearest hole notch you flick that in
there you slide that in there and then
you choose one of the uncountably
infinite number of positions you can put
that although frankly there it doesn't
really move once it's on so that's uh
that's that's quite it's quite tight
actually i'm gonna
it also doubles as a tourniquet so it's
got casio in case you forget where you
buy it and water resistant alarm chrono
so the chrono obviously for time means
that if it gets wet then the alarm goes
off
and then there's all sorts of tiny tiny
writing in there this lap reset
should you be you know doing competitive
calculations and you're timing yourself
per lap there's a date thing uh sig on
off should you wish to turn the sig on
or off start stop alarm on off and of
course all the digits from zero right
through up to nine buttons on the side
over here so that one there is going to
take that's just oh it must be in
calculator mode so let's do uh let's
just do a calculation so let's do seven
now i'm gonna do times where's times
this time is that times that times this
is six
oh this oh right okay so i need to clear
where's clear what do you reckon uh is
that clear
that's plus that's plus i'm adding i'm
adding now now i'm adding and i wanted
to be clearing what's that that's okay
okay let's try again okay so seven
point seven i've now done point seven
uh okay maybe this is clear
that's clear oh that's clear okay right
of course why waste a perfectly good but
that's been repurposed for clearing
seven
times good let's do one seventh times
point
one four
two
eight
five oh there's seven i hit seven four
because it's on the wrong oh okay so
this is going to take some getting used
to they're not well labeled as to which
one is which i'm sure you get use that
pretty quick so seven times point
one
four
two
eight got it
five
seven
well i'll round up to a two should we
get two on the end there equals hey okay
so it equals one point zero zero zero
zero zero zero four which i'm gonna i'm
gonna allow because i did around uh one
seventh a decent amount very quickly do
one divide
zero
equals
error it says e that's good that's good
to see uh and we will do one quick test
of precision so we'll do one
divided by
nine times
nine
equals okay so again it hasn't given us
one it's given us point nine nine nine
no no no which i mean given the size i
would say even though it's not very
accurate if you average the accuracy
versus size or accuracy per volume of
the calculator this one is still doing
pretty well like i said before it does
sit very neatly on your wrist uh so it
and it moves with if there's an exact
one to one match between where your
wrist is and where the watch ends up
which is quite nice and and the big
feature is uh that we've deliberately
got the model of the casio watch which
walter white wears in breaking bad and
so this watch is good for both on the
fly calculations when teaching chemistry
or cooking methamphetamine scores for
the casio data bank calculator watch for
the display i gave it a four it's pretty
small in terms of functionality a two
it's the bare minimum accuracy five
ergonomics ten i mean it's attached to
your wrist cred infinite
durability and eight it certainly fared
better than i was which gives us a grand
total of infinity which is an average of
infinity because i'm not allowed
infinity as a score i can change the
cred to just go up to 11 which makes a
new total of 40 and that's an average of
6.6 recurring